see the Sun coming up here in Manhattan
welcome back to CBS this morning
the Manhattan truck attack happened just
behind us here along the Hudson River
Greenway the Riverside path is used by
thousands of people every day to walk
run and bicycle New York City has more
than a thousand miles of bike routes and
more than 200 bike lanes just in
Manhattan but that type of public space
is increasingly being targeted by
terrorists with the tactic that is
difficult to prevent it's a recipe for
terror we've seen before a driver in a
speeding truck or van killing and
injuring scores of people in their path
from nice to Berlin in 2016 in Barcelona
to London this year the origin of the
attacks points to this 2010 issue of
al-qaeda's inspire magazine a photo of a
pickup truck and the headline the
ultimate mowing machine the terror
groups instructions mirror Tuesday's
attack in New York among the ideal
targets pedestrian only locations narrow
spots are also better because it gives
less chance for people to run away today
there was a loss of innocent life in
lower Manhattan the dead and injured
were just going about their days heading
off from work or from school or enjoying
the afternoon Sun on bicycles listed is
the busiest bicycle path in the u.s. the
Hudson River Greenway stretches nearly
the entire West Side of Manhattan the
section cyfle acai path targeted is no
more than 20 feet wide lined with tennis
courts and parks on one side and a busy
multi-lane highway on the other steel
posts are installed at several
intersections but none that stops iPod
from getting through we went and did
extensive outreach to the truck rental
business
NYPD Deputy Commissioner John Miller
says the department has spent years
preparing for vehicle borne attacks we
visited over a hundred and forty eight
truck rental locations in this area the
obvious ones u-haul Ryder Home Depot etc
and talked about suspicious indicators
after attacks on the german christmas
market after nice we repeated those
visits two more times
the industry has had a high level of
awareness on this matter from the NYPD
John Miller is right and in fact we
reached out to several rental truck
companies u-haul says it uses a
combination of data and techniques
influenced by law enforcement to decide
whether each customer should be given a
key home depot says it's their standard
approach for employees to alert
authorities if they see anything
suspicious in their stores and it
appears that he did not set up on the
red flags when he rented this vehicle
just at about two o'clock yesterday in
New Jersey let's send it back now to
Gail in studio 57 Gail we're always
working on this thank you very much Nora